JavaScript It's a Wonderful programming
language to learn for beginners it's
also a horrible programming language to
learn for beginners on one hand you can
build almost anything with it and get a
job anywhere if you master it on the
other hand it's weird ugly and
surrounded by a dystopian Wasteland of
Frameworks and libraries don't want to
sound like a dick or nothing but uh it
says on your chart that you're [ __ ] up
welcome to JavaScript 101 over the next
few minutes you'll learn 101 different
things you need to know about JavaScript
like how to use it where to use it and
why it is the way it is by the end of
this video you'll be able to build a
website a mobile app a desktop app a
server an operating system artificial
intelligence and all kinds of other
stuff you shouldn't build with it it was
created in 1993 by Brendan Ike at
Netscape at the time the web browser was
cutting edge technology that connected
everybody on the planet via the World
Wide Web now that I've gotten on the
internet I'd rather be on my computer
than doing just about anything at the
time websites were completely static
with pure HTML JavaScript was designed
as an easy to use high level language to
help developers make these websites
interactive today it's arguably the most
popular language in the world and its
standard implementation is called
ecmascript and is the default language
in all web browsers in fact it's the
only code that natively runs in a
browser aside from webassembly however
the browser is not the only runtime and
you can also run JavaScript code on a
server thanks to tools like node.js and
Dino as the name implies JavaScript is a
scripting language that means you can
execute code on the Fly by opening up
the console in your browser Dev tools to
run some code that changes the
appearance of a website at any time it's
interpreted line by line as opposed to
other languages like C that are compiled
ahead of time however interpreted is not
the most accurate term to use here under
the hood of the browser there's an
engine called V8 it makes JavaScript run
extremely fast by taking your code and
converting it to machine code with a
process called Just in Time compilation
but none of this stuff really matters
let's jump into some code to use
JavaScript on a web page you'll first
need an HTML document inside of which
we'll have a a script tag you can write
code inside the tag directly or
reference an external file with the
source attribute now to say hello world
use console log which is javascript's
built-in tool for printing to the
standard output now open the HTML file
in a browser and you should see the
value printed out in the dev tools there
are several different ways to Define
variables the most common of which today
is let start by giving it a name which
will normally be in camelcase then
assign a value to it it's a dynamically
typed language which means no data type
annotations are necessary in this case
I've assigned a number which is one of
the seven primitive data types built
into the language however we don't need
to assign the variable a value right now
because it can be reassigned later
without an assignment it automatically
uses the Primitive value of undefined as
its default value however we can
explicitly represent an empty value
using null and later on we could
reassign that same variable to a string
it's an entirely different data type but
that's perfectly okay now any value
that's not a primitive will inherit from
the object class but more on that later
right now now we need to talk about this
semicolon technically semicolons are
optional because if you leave them out
the JavaScript parser will add them
automatically in real life JavaScript
developers will often fight to the death
over whether or not to use semicolons
but let is not the only way to define a
variable another common option is const
which is used for variables that cannot
be reassigned later but the original way
to declare a variable is VAR I would
recommend ignoring its existence
altogether although you will find it out
in the wild the reason we have so many
different ways to Define variables has
to do with the lexical environment which
determines where variables work and
where they don't there's a global scope
which is where we are right now which
means this variable will be available
everywhere however if we Define a
variable inside a function it then
becomes local to that function and
cannot be used outside of it and finally
if you have a statement like an if
condition variables can be scoped inside
the braces or block unless you use VAR
for that variable which is not block
scope in which case it will be hoisted
up into the local scope for that
function and trust me you don't want
that weirdness in your life when the
function keyword is used by itself it's
called a function definition or
statement functions are one of the main
building blocks in JavaScript and they
work by taking an input or argument then
optionally return a value that can be
used somewhere else now functions are
just objects which means they can also
be used as Expressions allowing them to
be used as variables or to construct
higher order functions where a function
is used as an argument or a return value
functions can also be nested to create a
closure that encapsulates data and logic
from the rest of the program normally
when you call a function that has a
variable with a primitive value it's
stored on the call stack which is the
browser's short-term memory however when
you create a closure the inner function
can still access variables in the outer
function even after the initial function
call that happens because JavaScript
automatically stores the data in the
outer function in the Heap memory which
will persist between function calls
you'll rarely have to think about that
as a developer but what you're more
likely to run into is this it's a
keyword that references an object and
based on how a function is called when
called from the global scope it
references the window object in the
browser however if that same function is
attached to an object and called by that
object this will be a reference to that
object and you can manually bind a
function to some other object using the
bind method this can be rather confusing
but modern JavaScript has another way to
define functions using the arrow syntax
Arrow functions don't have their own
this value and they're always Anonymous
which makes them ideal for function
Expressions now one last thing you need
to know about functions is that when
passing arguments A Primitive like a
number is passed by value which means a
copy is created of the original variable
however if the argument is an object
that means it's stored in the Heap and
it's passed by reference that means
multiple parts of the code might be
mutating the same object speaking of
which let's talk about objects the
easiest way to define one is with the
object literal syntax using braces but
there's also an object type that can be
created with a Constructor using the new
keyword an object contains a collection
of key value pairs or properties and
values what's interest scene is that
objects can inherit properties from each
other thanks to a mechanism called the
Prototype chain every object has a
private property that links to exactly
one prototype this differs from
class-based inheritance found in many
other languages because we're dealing
with real objects that take out memory
as opposed to abstract classes in your
code now what's confusing is Javascript
supports object oriented programming
with a class keyword however classes are
just syntactic sugar for prototypal
inheritance and objects a class can
define a Constructor which is a function
that's called when the object is first
created it can also have properties and
optionally create Getters and Setters to
access them and it more easily
encapsulates functions by organizing
them as methods on an object instance or
making them Global to the class name
with the static keyword in addition to
objects JavaScript has a bunch of
built-in data structures like an array
for holding a dynamic collection of
indexed items or a set to hold a
collection of unique items or map which
also holds a key value pair like an
object but can be more easily looped
over along with a variety of other
features now what you should also know
at this point is that JavaScript is
garbage collected that means it will
automatically deallocate objects from
memory when they're no longer referenced
in your code however when you have a map
all the properties will always be
referenced if that's not optimal there's
a weak map and weak set that contain
properties that can be garbage collected
to reduce memory usage now that we have
a basic idea of what JavaScript looks
like let's talk about one of its most
interesting features which is its
non-blocking event Loop normally when
you write code in a script it's executed
synchronously line by line which means
the next line can't start until the
previous line finishes with an event
Loop we can write asynchronous code in
JavaScript that runs in a separate
thread pool while the rest of the
application continues to execute this is
really important because modern websites
often have multiple things going on at
the same time but they only have access
to a single thread for computing called
the main thread without asynchronous
code it would be impossible to multitask
an easy way to demonstrate this is with
set timeout which takes a function as an
argument but won't actually really call
that function until X number of
milliseconds have elapsed this is called
a callback function because it gets
enqueued in the event Loop will need to
be called back later when it's ready to
execute on the main thread callback
functions are very common but when
they're overused and become too deeply
nested it leads to a situation called
callback hell luckily there are better
ways to write async code like a promise
A promise is a wrapper for a value
that's unknown right now but that will
resolve to a value in the future like
maybe a call to a third party API that
resolves to some data if something goes
wrong the promise can reject to raise an
error now the consumer of the promise
can use methods like then and catch to
handle these two possible outcomes or
better yet you can define an async
function that will automatically return
a promise then in the body of the
function we can pause its execution
using the await keyword to wait for
other promises to resolve and this
results in nice readable code however in
order to implement error handling you'll
want to wrap this code in a try catch
block now as your code grows in
complexity it won't all fit in a single
file luckily we can use modules to share
code between files by default all the
code in a file or module is private to
that file however if there's some code
we want to use elsewhere like a function
we can make it a default export this
allows us to go into a different file
and use an import statement to use the
function there as well it's also
possible to export multiple values from
a single file and then import them by
name in the other file but often what
you'll do in JavaScript land is use code
written by an entirely different
developer the largest JavaScript package
manager is npm when you install a
package from npm it downloads its code
into the node modules folder in your
project it also provides a package Json
file that will list out all the
dependencies used in your project now
let's go into the code and assume we're
building a website on the web the code
will run in the browser which is based
on the document object model where the
UI is represented as a tree of HTML
elements or nodes the browser provides
apis to interact with these nodes with
the most important object being the
document the document allows us to grab
an individual dual HTML element using a
method called query selector it takes a
CSS selector as an argument and will
find the HTML element that has the same
class Name ID or tag name it returns an
instance of the element class which
itself has a variety of properties and
methods you get information about it or
change its behavior in addition we can
grab multiple elements at the same time
using query selector at all most
importantly we can listen to events that
happen to it like when a button is
clicked with add event listener we can
assign a function that will be called
whenever that event takes place much of
web development revolves around
listening to events and updating the UI
accordingly however one thing that many
developers dislike about vanilla
JavaScript is that it results in
imperative code where the UI is mutated
directly many developers now use
front-end Frameworks that produce
declarative code where the UI is a
function of its input data these
libraries encapsulate JavaScript HTML
and CSS into components which are then
used together to form a component tree
to represent the UI most importantly
inside a component data is reactive it
can be bound from the JavaScript
directly to the HTML that means anytime
data changes the UI will be updated
automatically now after you build a
complete Javascript app you'll need to
take all of your JavaScript files and
combine them into a single bundle that
can be used by the browser to handle
this process efficiently you'll need a
tool called a module bundler like Veet
or webpack one problem though is that
sometimes this Javascript file can get
too big which affects the page load
performance and this can be measured by
the network waterfall in your browser
Dev tools luckily it's possible to split
this JavaScript bundle into multiple
files then use Dynamic Imports in your
code to only import that JavaScript when
it becomes needed now JavaScript doesn't
just run in the browser but also on the
server node.js is the most popular
runtime and you can execute JavaScript
code at any time using the node command
this opens the door to Frameworks like
electron which combine nodejs with a
browser to create full stack desktop
apps with JavaScript or IOS and Android
apps with react native at this point
you've got 99 problems and JavaScript is
every single one of them if you want to
make life easier use a tool like
typescript or eslant that does static
analysis to improve your code quality
congratulations for reaching the end of
JavaScript 101 if you want to go beyond
this video I just released a brand new
JavaScript course on fireship i o this
video is the introduction to that course
which is followed by a deeper dive into
these Concepts then we work on some
Hands-On projects with a bunch of
quizzes along the way thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one